In the previous lecture we
introduced random variables,
probability mass functions
and expectations.
In this lecture we continue
with the development of
various concepts associated
with random variables.
There will be three
main parts.
In the first part we define
the variance of a random
variable, and calculate
it for some of our
familiar random variables.
Basically the variance is a
quantity that measures the
amount of spread, or the
dispersion of a probability
mass functions.
In some sense, it quantifies the
amount of randomness that
is present.
Together with the expected
value, the variance summarizes
crisply some of the qualitative
properties of the
probability mass function.
In the second part we discuss
conditioning.
Every probabilistic concept or
result has a conditional
counterpart.
And this is true for probability
mass functions,
expectations and variances.
We define these conditional
counterparts and then develop
the total expectation theorem.
This is a powerful tool that
extends our familiar total
probability theorem and allows
us to divide and conquer when
we calculate expectations.
We then take the opportunity
to dive deeper into the
properties of geometric random
variables, and use a trick
based on the total expectation
theorem to
calculate their mean.
In the last part we show how to
describe probabilistically
the relation between multiple
random variables.
This is done through a so-called
joint probability
mass function.
We take the occasion to
generalize the expected value
rule, and establish a further
linearity property of
expectations.
We finally illustrate the power
of these tools through
the calculation of the expected
value of a binomial
random variable.